bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle après-midi
deux direct sur public sénat dans un
instant vous allez pouvoir suivre les
explications de vote sur le projet de
loi sur le renseignement
à 18h15 ses preuves par 3 avec comme
invité stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture et porte parole du
gouvernement et à 19 heures c'est votre
journal 24 heures sénat présenté par
delphine girard
mais d'abord nous accueillons françois
zocchetto le président du groupe
centriste au sénat bonfim jours le sénat
vient de voter la réforme du
renseignement
deux cent cinquante et une voix pour 68
voix contre
quelles sont les principales
modifications apportées par les
sénateurs
c'est un exercice particulièrement
difficile pour le législateur que de de
statuer sur la question du renseignement
puisque vous savez il s'agit pour nous
de concilier deux choses a priori
opposés c'est le respect des libertés
individuelles et puis la lutte va se
donner les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme
donc le texte qui nous venaient de
l'assemblée nationale nous paraissait
insuffisamment encadrée contrôlée
donc la commission des lois du sénat
avec son président rapporteur et et avec
l'appui de du président de la commission
aux affaires étrangères l'ancien premier
ministre qui jean py raffin qui connaît
très bien c'est ces questions là c'était
force et de renforcer les garanties
individuelles
nous voulons encadrer strictement
l'action des services de renseignement
en particulier nous souhaitons que les
agents de l'espionnage puisque c'est ça
dont il s'agit
puissent être enfin soit responsable
pénalement de leurs actes nous
souhaitons aussi que la procédure soit
contrôlé par un organisme indépendant
c'est donc la commission nationale de
contrôle
qui a été créé c'est ce qui a été fait
les moules voire de la commune trolls
ont été renforcés absolument et puis
nous souhaitons aussi que le recours
juridictionnel soit réel à tous les
stades de la procédure car dans le texte
initial du gouvernement et de
l'assemblée nationale vient le rôle du
juge était un peu oubliée donc là nous
avons réintroduit la possibilité de
saisir le juge administratif ou
judiciaire à tous les moments de ces
procédures mais je dois vous dire quand
même que ce texte laisse un malaise et
que chacun vote mais un peu contraint et
forcé car quelque part nous avons
l'impression d'être un peu quand même
les victimes des événements du
terrorisme et et de devoir ainsi donner
un coup de canif aux grands principes de
la démocratie à savoir le respect de la
vie privée le respect des libertés
individuelles c'est cher payé quand même
qu est ce que vous êtes
non je dis que nous étions contraints au
compromis vu les circonstances
mais qu'il faut considérer que ce texte
n'est pas définitif d'abord parce que
nous sommes confrontés également à
l'évolution très rapide des techniques
et ce qui est valable aujourd'hui ne
l'est plus ne le sera plus demain
songez que le dernier texte que nous
avions à la matière datait de 91 est pas
cool la téléphonie mobile était
balbutiante et où internet n'existait
pas donc il faut pas se faire
d'illusions il faudra revoir ses textes
régulièrement et peut-être peut-être
revenir sur certaines dispositions
considérant qu' elles sont inadaptés ou
qu'elles sont trop réductrice des
libertés individuelles
un mot sur l'avenir de ce texte en
commission mixte paritaire
est-ce que ce compromis sortie du sénat
va le sénat a fait un travail vraiment
très sérieux un travail même assez assez
technique mais un travail de connaisseur
puisque les deux présidents rapporteur
qui ont qui ont guidé le
la réflexion sont des sommes qui sont
parfaitement au courant du
fonctionnement de l'état à son sommet et
je n'imagine pas que les députés les
députés ne puisse pas retenir les
apports du sénat je crois qu'ils vont
vraiment dans le bon sens lui de
protéger les français protéger les
libertés
tout en étant conscient que la lutte
contre le terrorisme et contre la grande
criminalité nous oblige est réaliste
française à quetta merci merci beaucoup
tout film donc direction l'hémicycle
pour ce vote sur la réforme du
renseignement
la parole est maintenant à madame cécile
cukierman pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen il avait la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 1
comme je l'avais évoqué en introduction
des débats ce sujet aurait largement
justifié que la navette parlementaire
laisse aux deux assemblées le temps
nécessaire pour parvenir à un équilibre
délicat à trouver entre sécurité et
liberté
la complexité de cette question et la
nature même des activités de
renseignement mérite un débat de fond à
la hauteur de l'enjeu
un débat que la procédure accélérée ne
permet pas sur la forme du débat nous
regrettons également que celui ci était
été morcelé en différentes séances
jonglant d'un article à l'autre parfois
même au sein d'un même article à travers
d'autres texte discuté la semaine passée
sur le fond et malgré toute la
détermination du gouvernement à nous
démontrer le bien fondé des dispositions
qu'il soit mettre en place nous n'en
sommes toujours pas convaincus
les modifications que la commission des
lois a apporté au projet nombreux défis
pas l'état d'esprit
en intégrant techniques de profilage et
algorithmes de prédiction le paradigme
est inversée en matière de surveillance
au lieu de partir de la cible pour
trouver les données on part des données
pour trouver la cible ce projet ce
projet de loi sur le renseignement est
essentiellement légitimé par sa
référence au terrorisme
mais il a un contenu beaucoup plus large
puisqu'il permettra de surveiller dans
de multiples chants les intérêts
économiques et scientifiques français
ceux de la politique étrangère la
criminalité la délinquance organisée les
fameuses violences collectives dans sa
rédaction actuelle le texte ouvre donc
la voie à des dérives potentielles de
surveillance de groupes ou d'individus
entendant contester les politiques
publiques
on peut dès lors penser aux
organisations syndicales mais pas
seulement
en dénonçant certaines pratiques
illégales ou amoral d'entreprises
nationales touchant à des questions
environnementales de santé publique par
exemple ainsi qu'à ce qui peut avoir
trait à l'énergie la distribution de
l'eau les nouvelles technologies
l'armement les groupes de consommateurs
et lanceurs d'alert sont également dans
le collimateur car susceptible de fêtes
de nuire aux intérêts économiques de la
france
al'inverse la prévention de l'espionnage
économique industriel et scientifique
dans le respect du droit à l'information
que nous vous proposions par voie
d'amendement était un motif précis et
légitime prévenons largement les risques
de dérives de surveillance politique
illégitime des citoyens hélas cet
amendement comme tous les autres du
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
n'a pas trouvé d'écho dans cet hémicycle
ou alors si faible en parallèle aux
motifs justifiant le recours aux
services de renseignements la france se
dote d'un arsenal de techniques
intrusive les boîtes noires
surveilleront les comportements suspects
en surveillant toutes les données y
compris celle de se considérer comme non
suspecte
donc tout le monde les algorithmes
aideront à cette surveillance en
repérant les gens qui sont en contact
avec les gens qui sont en contact avec
d'autres gens qui sont en contact avec
une personne potentiellement lourds je
cite le système de contrôle permanent
des individus est une épreuve permanente
sans point final une enquête mais avant
tout délit en dehors de tout crime
c'est une enquête de suspicion générale
et a priori de l'individu qui permet
contrôle et une pression de tous les
instants de suivre l'individu dans
chacune de ses démarches de voir s'il
est régulier ou irréguliers ranger ou
dissiper normal ou anormal
il semblerait bien que l'on tende vers
cette société punitif que décrivent et
michel foucault dans son cours au
collège de france de 1972 à 1973
pilier de l'ère de la suspicion ce texte
représente une grande menace pour la
sauvegarde de nos libertés individuelles
grande menace aussi pour plusieurs
professions notamment pour le
journalisme de fait les pratiques de
surveillance indifférenciée vont tarir
les sources car l'anonymat ne pourra
désormais plus être garantie en effet
comment un hymne s'y cacher reconnaîtra
si un individu s'apparente ou non un
journaliste avant l'interception
d'intercepter ces communications
électroniques
je vous le rappelle la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme avait précisé dès
la sphère classe de 1978 que les états
ne saurait au nom de la lutte contre le
terrorisme prendre n'importe quel monde
mesure jugée par eux approprié risquant
de saper voire de détruire la démocratie
au motif même de la défendre au moment
où le congrès américain adopte un texte
qui pour la première fois et cornes
patriot act
force est de constater que sans jouer
dans la même catégorie est vrai
renseignements français américains
convergent
d'ailleurs dans une tribune envoyait à
quelques médias dont libération edouard
soul ce modèle nous met en garde en
dehors des états unis
les chefs des services secrets en
australie au canada et en france sont
exploités des tragédies récentes afin
d'essayer d'obtenir de nouveaux pouvoirs
intrusif
malgré des preuves éclatantes que ceux
ci n'auraient pas permis d'empêcher ces
attaques car évidemment au delà du champ
d'application de la surveillance et du
recul de nos libertés individuelles
auxquelles certains n'ayant rien à
cacher se disent prêts à renoncer
se pose la question de l'efficacité d'un
tel arsenal lors de l'examen du texte
monsieur bah le rapporteur nous a parlé
d'une botte de fond aimanté la formule
est révélatrice de la grande confusion
qui règne autour de l'efficacité des
dispositifs et pour cause tous les
professionnels du secteur s'accordent à
dire que ces dispositifs ne déjoueront
aucun attentat des informations relevant
de la menace seront captés certes
puisque toute information électronique
peut l'être mais comment s'effectuera le
tri le projet de loi renseignements ou
l'illusion du risque zéro donc mais nous
avons tendance à penser que les citoyens
ne sont pas dues comme en témoignent les
138 milles qui ont signé la pétition
contre le projet de loi et qui pose une
question très pertinente qui nous
protègera contre ce qui nous protège et
qui délivre aujourd'hui à travers ce
texte
l'inquiétude de nombreux citoyens
multiples craintes donc soulève ce
projet car c'est en répondant à cette
simple question qui surveille les
surveillants que la loi devrait
s'assurer de l' équilibre entre
surveillance massive et protection des
libertés individuelles
il n'en est rien malgré encore une fois
les tentatives de la commission des lois
d'apporter plus de pouvoir et de
légitimité à la scène ctr concernant la
proposition de loi relative à la
nomination du président de cette
commission jean terminerait nous pensons
qu'il s'agit là de la moindre des choses
nous sommes cependant opposé aux
conditions draconiennes de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
quant au contrôle effectif des
nominations réservés au parlement
c'est pourquoi notre groupe s'abstiendra
lors du vote de cette proposition
vous l'aurez compris l'ensemble des
membres du groupe communiste citoyen et
républicain votre contre ce projet de
loi relatifs aux renseignements
nous continuerons à nous mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs et des citoyens
contre ce texte lors de la cmp notamment
et suivront très attentivement et
recours présidentielle et parlementaires
dans le conseil constitutionnel je vous
informe que les sénateurs du groupe crc
s'adresseront également de manière
officielle à ce conseil constitutionnel
dans une lettre publique notamment pour
s'enquérir du bien fondé du déploiement
des techniques
d'une surveillance de masse tard dans
les fêtes c'est vers cela a été notre
dos merci va chers collègues
la parole est qu à notre collègue le
président jacques mézard pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique social et
européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
les débats sur le présent projet de loi
ont été riche intense nous permettant de
mettre en exergue les aspérités de
l'élaboration d'une politique publique
du renseignement qui perturbe notre
démocratie entre des impératifs
contradictoires mais qu'il faut pourtant
réconcilier ce fut tout l'enjeu de nos
échanges
trouver le bon équilibre entre la
nécessaire sécurité de tous et
l'indispensable liberté de chacun
avons-nous atteint la vertu qu'aristote
dans son éthique à nicomaque définit
comme l'ouvragé convenablement exécuté
c'est à dire celui auquel on ne peut
rien enlevé ni rien ajouter tout
additions et taux de suppression ne
pouvant que lui enlever de sa perfection
et cet équilibre parfait la conservant
peut être pouvons nous considérer que
cela est le cas dans le contexte troublé
actuel qui a vu les événements de début
janvier et qui comme nous l'ont rappelé
à maintes reprises les ministres le
drian et cazeneuve
ce qui encore accru les risques
d'attentât terroriste sur notre pays
mais nous aurons j'en suis persuadé à y
revenir dans les prochaines années
à la lueur de la connaissance empirique
qui aura été la nôtre
rappelons qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un texte
sur le terrorisme c'est déjà fait mais
d'un texte sur le renseignement dans
tous ses aspects criminalité terrorisme
économie défense si ce texte était en
préparation et c'est la réalité avant
les attentats de janvier il faut quand
même convenir que la proche et
l'acceptation du texte se fait en partie
dans l'émotion de ces événements
dramatiques
le projet de loi crée un cadre
législatif à la politique publique du
renseignement
pour mettre notre pays en conformité
avec les standards démocratiques comme
l'ont fait avant nous l'allemagne le
royaume uni nous n'étions pas en avance
sur notre temps et il faut saluer une
décision visant à encadrer des pratiques
totaka totalement au culte en les
exposant à la lumière pour cela au moins
un texte était déjà nécessaire le
renseignement engage inévitablement une
discussion sur les fins et les moyens
sur les parts d'ombré de la vie de la
cité qui échappent en partie au dialogue
démocratique
cette loi-cadre qu'ils aient fini à la
fois les principes et les finalités de
la politique publique du renseignement
et l'utilisation des techniques de
recueil doit être le signe de la
maturité de notre démocratie car il ne
saurait mes chers collègues existait de
démocratie sans renseignement mais le
renseignement peut se passer de
démocratie la question de fond c'est
comme assurer un contrôle efficace de
l'utilisation des nouvelles techniques
et en particulier numérique technique
profondément intrusive de la vie privée
n'entreront assemblée a apporté sa
contribution en renforçant les garanties
apportées à la mise en oeuvre des
techniques de renseignement notamment en
limitant les finalités permettant la
mise en oeuvre de la procédure d'urgence
absolue ou en accroissant les pouvoirs
de contrôle de la commission nationale
en particulier nous saluons la
consécration d'un recours juridictionnel
suite à un avis défavorable de la
commission nationale portant sur une
intrusion dans un lieu à usage
d'habitation
le conseil d'état devra alors statué en
24 heures et fait notable le recours
sera suspensif de l'autorisation du
premier ministre
si nous ne nous opposons pas par
principe aux techniques nouvelles de
renseignements de base
nous nous interrogeons sur l'arrêt fiq a
cité parmi lesquels les ihm 6-4 cher où
les algorithmes comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le mentionner la probabilité
d'identifier correctement un terroriste
est infinitésimal la solution
dernièrement choisie par les états unis
nous paraît plus conforme au respect des
libertés
le freedom act a prévu un encadrement
plus strict de la collecte des
métadonnées par la nsa
désormais celles ci seront stockées par
les opérateurs télécoms et les services
de renseignement devront motiver leur
requête pour y accéder au cas par cas
le conseil d'état le nôtre vient par
ailleurs de transmettre une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité sur
des articles du code de la sécurité
intérieure créée par la loi de
programmation militaire 2014 2009 2019
à l'instar des dispositions qui ont été
votées dans le présent projet de loi ses
articles prévoit la possibilité pour
l'administration de recueillir des
informations et des documents auprès des
intermédiaires techniques de l'internet
principalement à des fins de sécurité
nationale dans les conditions et limites
qu'il fixe à ce titre peuvent notamment
être recueilli des données de connaître
de connexion mes chers collègues
la solution d'équilibré en matière de
renseignement pénitentiaire a également
répondu à nos inquiétudes sur la mise en
oeuvre des techniques de renseignement
par l'administration pénitentiaire et je
tiens à saluer l'initiative de notre
rapporteur président de la commission
des lois
nous regrettons par contre à nouveau que
ce soit le juge administratif qui était
chargée de la protection des libertés
individuelles devenant ainsi le juge de
droit commun en matière de voies de fait
nous regrettons également et cela ne
surprendra personne que les débats n'est
pas permis des avancées suffisantes en
matière de protection des parlementaires
et des professions protégées dont les
avocats et les magistrats
madame la garde des sceaux avait avancé
à avancer des propositions en ce sens
en nous indiquant que des réflexions
étaient en cours sur l'habilitation
secret défense d'un bâtonnier honoraires
nous espérons que ces réflexions
aboutiront dans les prochains mois dans
un essai récemment publié renseignez les
démocraties renseigner en démocratie les
auteurs monsieur poussera ancien
directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure mais monsieur ier ancien
directeur adjoint du renseignement de la
dgse eux
soline que l'hyper politisation du
renseignement est un risque permanent
est important
je cite partout et toujours la tentation
existe d'utiliser les services pour
espionner des opposants voilà pourquoi
il est essentiel de prévoir des
garde-fous suffisamment puissant un
contrôle juridictionnel bien sûr mais
aussi une commission de contrôle dont la
vie pèserait sur la décision du pouvoir
exécutif dans l'avenir nos dix ces deux
auteurs le renseignement devra prendre
garde a continué à détecter les mener
contre un ordre social et
internationales sans participer à la
fabrication de cet ennemi
nous avons écouté nous avons écouté au
cours de ces débats ceux qui ont
l'expérience des responsabilités de
l'état à commencer par monsieur le
premier ministre raffarin et par
monsieur mise de l'intérieur nous avons
aussi écouter mes chers collègues les
inquiétudes exprimées dans chacun des
six groupes parlementaires du sénat
et c'est révélateur d'un débat de fond
qui ne saurait être occultée
ainsi en cette matière comme dans toutes
celles qui comptent pour la société
pouvons nous dire avec aristote toujours
que l'ecc c'est une faute et le manque
provoque le blâme
monsieur mise de l'intérieur notre
confiance en vous et j'ose le dire aux
ministres présents est intact mais notre
attachement viscéral au principe des
pans défendues depuis toujours ici par
notre groupe est aussi intact et pour
toutes ces raisons parce que nous
recherchons en permanence
l' équilibre entre les droits et les
devoirs le rdse exprimera avons
diversifié mais majoritairement un vote
d'abstention
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président
pour le sénateur non-inscrit et pour 3
minutes
la parole est à notre collègue robert
navarro
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi fait couler beaucoup
d'encre il nous avons tous reçu des
dizaines de mails de la part de citoyens
préoccupés ce projet de loi mettra-t-il
en place une surveillance de masse
geraghty la france dans les bras de
nouveau big brother
pour moi la réponse était clairement non
ce n'est pas l'équivalent des lois
liberticides de voter aux états unis
après le 11 septembre le fameux patriote
at il y a là ni transfert de pouvoir
massive vers le président de la
république ni création de commissions
militaires pour juger les terroristes ni
autorisation d'usagé de la torture notre
arsenal n'est donc pas un droit
déception c'est pourquoi je le soutiens
et je le voterai ce projet de loi me
fait penser aux radars personne ici n'en
conteste l'utilité et le rôle des
valeurs les moyens de technologie que
mis en place dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme reviennent exactement aux
mêmes et ne porte pas atteinte à la vie
privée
c'est d'ailleurs amusant que ce qui
compte est bon nombre d'entre eux sans
souci et de désinformation en face book
et autres géants du web que même la
stasi n'aurait pas osé collectés bien
sûr cette loi utilise les nouvelles
technologies
c'est ce qui fait peur c'est d'ailleurs
un point sur lequel je partage les
inquiétudes exprimées le quantitatif
nuit au qualitatif
si l'accès aux flux des données des
théories c'est indispensable
il doit être un outil au service du
renseignement pas au coeur de la lutte
sous peine de décevoir
en fait ce projet de loi qui va
fluidifier l'action est indispensable
des pouvoirs publics dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne doit pas nous
faire passer à côté de réflexion de fond
que nous devons mener les attentats du
11-septembre d'abord la montée en
puissance de les thèses lamy quatorze
ans après la guerre la paix le crime au
21ème siècle ces mots changent de sens
avec qui concluront nous montrer
et de paix personne malheureusement il
est clair qu'à côté de la mondialisation
économique se développe en parallèle une
forme de guerre civile mondiale
permanente
face à cette menace émergente la seule
réponse est une solidarité mondiale
elle émerge timidement autour de
phénomènes globaux comme le changement
climatique
les rames des migrations plus près de
nous la mobilisation mondiale après
l'attaqué odieuses contre charlie hebdo
montre que face à la n l'humanité
capable de ceux des femmes de lacie au
japon des etats-unis à la tunisie des
millions d'hommes et de femmes se sont
levés contre la barbarie
la démocratie ne pourra vaincre que sur
ses valeurs et surtout nous ne devons ni
pour m ni rêver d'un risque zéro
comme dirait non sans humour le
philosophe emmanuel qu'à la seule paix
durable et celle malheureusement des
cimetières la parole est maintenant au
président françois zocchetto qui est à
quelques difficultés à venir jusqu'à
nous pour le groupe u10 union centriste
avait la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'exercice est difficile pour le
législateur aujourd'hui comment
concilier le respect des libertés
publiques fondements de la démocratie
avec l'efficacité dans la lutte contre
les déviances du terrorisme et
l'exercice était aussi difficile pour
nos deux présidents rapporteur philippe
à jean pierre raffarin que ça lui
vraiment car c'est grâce à eux que nous
avons un texte que nous pouvons
sérieusement considérer aujourd'hui nous
avions besoin d'une loi
les précédents textes datait de 1991 à
une époque où la téléphonie mobile était
balbutiante
à une époque où internet ni
n'hésitez pas nous avions besoin d'une
loi pour sécuriser les procédures des
agents du renseignement qui sont souvent
à l'origine de procédures judiciaires
délicate
nous avions besoin d'une loi pour
apporter des garde fous supplémentaires
dans la protection des libertés
publiques nous avions besoin d'une loi
pourra avoir un contrôle indépendant et
que le pouvoir exécutif et plus
particulièrement les services du premier
ministre ne puisse pas avoir une liberté
totale en matière de renseignement mais
nous avions aussi besoin d'un texte qui
permette le recours au juge qu'ils
soient administratifs ou judiciaires à
tous les niveaux de ces de ces
procédures alors je comprends les je
comprends les craintes exprimées par
tous ceux d'entre nous toutes celles
d'entre nous qui ont émis des critiques
et qui les maintiennent aujourd'hui car
au delà du texte même qui nous est
présenté nous sommes confrontés à un
double problème
tout d'abord une confrontation avec
l'évolution des techniques
c'est pas nouveau mais ça s'accélère et
deuxièmement une confrontation avec le
développement du terrorisme
et c'est bien cette double confrontation
que nous avons du mal à assumer les uns
et les autres
alors encadrer la procédure d'urgence
absolue raccourcir les délais dans la
conservation des informations veiller à
ce que les algorithmes elle et m6
catcheur soit utilisé de la façon la
plus restreinte possible sont des
objectifs louables et je crois vraiment
que les propositions qui sont faites
vont dans le sens d'une réduction des
risques mais nous devons rester
extrêmement vigilants car nous devons au
delà du vote ou du non vote de ce texte
en tout cas de l'examen de ce texte
nous devons garder un contrôle permanent
sur les procédures
quelle est la responsabilité pénale des
agents du renseignement à chaque instant
nous devrons nous poser ses questions et
plus est
monde eux devront se poser la question
comment assurer un contrôle
parlementaire efficace
comment encadrer
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure les
services de l'exécutif et plus
particulièrement du premier ministre je
crois pouvoir dire que dans chaque
famille politique
nous observons des divergences sensible
il faut bien se garder entre nous d'en
faire des fossé d'incompréhension il n'y
a pas d'un côté ceux qui voudraient
lutter contre le terrorisme
et puis ce qui de l'autre côté ce serait
des baies à des grands principes de la
démocratie
vous savez bien que les choses sont
beaucoup plus complexes et il y a déjà
été dit que ce texte n'était pas un
texte de circonstance même si nous
l'étudions dans un contexte particulier
et douloureux
eh bien ces divergences qui existent
dans chaque famille elles existent aussi
au sein du groupe que je préside et donc
je précise qu'un certain nombre de
membres du groupe u10 ne voterons pas ce
texte pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées
tout à l'heure en attendant je crois que
notre devoir de législateur sera de
rester extrêmement attentif à
l'application des dispositions que nous
évoquons et en particulier nous devons
nous préparer à cette échéance de cinq
ans cinq ans c'est déjà un peu loin mon
avis mais enfin ne vaut une clause de
revoyure que pas du tout cette échéance
de cinq ans pour savoir si nous devons
revenir ou pas à ce moment sur certaines
dispositions dont nous prenons la
responsabilité que nous prenons
aujourd'hui la responsabilité
d'autoriser je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président n'a pas
roulé notre collègue jean jacques hyest
pour le groupe l'est républicain
nord-ouest monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
au nom de l'efficacité face au
développement de la menace terroriste
qui est hélas une réalité inquiétante
rien ne serait pire que de ne pas
respecter l'état de droit et les
libertés publiques
s'il faut affirmer la nécessité de la
prévention de tous les crimes et délits
qui pourrait détruire notre état et
notre société est bien entendu soutenir
l'action des services qui en sont
chargés il faut veiller en permanence à
la légalité de leurs actions c'est
l'objet du projet de loi dont vient de
délibérer sénat si la loi de 1991 a
constitué je vous l'assuré une véritable
révolution en ce qui concerne les
interceptions de sécurité
l'évolution des techniques en matière
télécommunications et d'internet
justifier un examen d'ensemble du
dispositif en ayant pour fil rouge le
respect du principe de proportionnalité
le contrôle effectif de différentes des
différents moyens de renseignements
utilisés car au nom de l'efficacité
véritable ou supposée
on ne saurait admettre que l'on abuse
autour du mois mais use de ce que permet
aujourd'hui la technique notre débat
fait suite à une importante résolution
votée sur la proposition de la
commission des affaires européennes il
ya quelques semaines qui avait pris en
compte ces préoccupations
mais bien sûr elle assistait avant tout
sur la responsabilité des acteurs privés
de l'internet et souhaité les voir mieux
impliquée dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
je crois qu'il faut rappeler l'apport
important de notre assemblée
grâce notamment à la commission des lois
et à son rapporteur président philippe
bas mais aussi à la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
avec l'expérience du premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin qui sait de quoi on
parle
quand on quand on a eu ses
responsabilités et nous devons saluer
combien il était important de définir
les principes
de la politique publique de
renseignement légalité des autorisations
de mise en oeuvre des techniques
précision des finalités clarification
des responsabilités respectives des
services pénitentiaires et des services
de renseignement ça a été un point
important notre débat en rappelant que
la prévention de la criminalité la
délinquance organisée on ne parle que de
terrorisme
elle est parfois liés au terrorisme
aujourd'hui mais ses comptes
elle constitue cette prévention de la
criminalité et de la délinquance
organisée le principal motif des
demandes de renseignements plus de 60 %
on oublie de le dire mais c'est quand
même important de le rappeler
l'application du principe de
proportionnalité a conduit notre
assemblée a strictement encadrer la
procédure d'urgence absolue à clarifier
la procédure d'urgence et le régime
applicable aux professions protégées et
à définir les délais de conservation
collectées par référence à la date du
recueil et non de la première
exploitation à titre personnel je
considère que le raccourcissement de
certains délais aurait constitué une
meilleure garantie car à quoi servent
des données qui ne serait pas rapidement
exploité le sénat surtout
considérablement renforcer à la fois les
pouvoirs de la commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
dont le président grâce à la loi
organique serait nommé avec la vie des
assemblées en insistant sur le fait
qu'elle doit disposer qu'elle doit
disposer cette commission d'un accès
direct permanent et complet au
renseignement et registre il faudra
vraiment qu'elle veille à ce qu'on y
fournissent bien toutes ces données et à
tout moment sur sa capacité à apprécier
la nécessité la proportionnalité des
mesures si on y ajoute l'amélioration de
la procédure de saisine du conseil
d'état le contrôle devrait être efficace
à condition que la formation de la
commission ne soit pas trop large parce
qu'autrement ça va se perdre et il y
aura plus aucune efficacité comme on l'a
déjà rappelé le sénat a assisté en
matière de délais dus
ti et d'utilisation des procédures
d'urgence sur la proportionnalité
les mesures les plus intransigeants et
intrusive étant réservé à la prévention
des actes terroristes ou d'atteinte à
l'indépendance et à la défense nationale
si le recueil des données de connexion
fait l'objet d'un encadrement strict
comme la géolocalisation les fameuses
îles cyclades cher la sonorisation des
locaux la captation d'image je pense
qu'on va pas en faire des dizaines de
milliers par an il faut insister sur ce
qui concerne les algorithmes dont la
définition a été bien précisé est
orientée sur la détection des connexions
les contenants et non des contenus est
très encadrée pas d'urgence autorisation
limitée
la craintes légitimes exprimées par
certains en ce qui concerne le risque
d'une surveillance généralisée ne me
paraît pas pertinente mais devrait être
levé par notre texte et il y avait
également lieu de préciser la notion de
captation informatiques notamment
l'accès à des données stockées dans un
système informatique
si long et si l'on ajoute à ce pauvre
dame à ce panorama trop cursif le
renforcement des mesures de surveillance
internationale le volet relatif aux
agents des services qui visent à les
garantir dans leurs actions mais aussi à
les responsabiliser
ce texte dans sa version sénatoriale
était équilibré entre exigences de
sécurité et protection des libertés
fondamentales à mes chers collègues si
ce projet de loi avait été présenté dans
un autre contexte politique
nul doute que le débat n'aurait pas été
aussi apaisée mais il faut rappeler que
le scénar il faut rappeler que le sénat
toujours toujours là oui je le dis si
bien droit toujours attaché à la défense
des libertés publiques améliorer le
texte initial dans cette perspective
c'est pourquoi le groupe l'est
républicain vote aura dans sa grande
majorité le projet de loi issu des
travaux du sénat en insistant bien
entendus sur la nécessité d'une
évaluation exhaustive dans un délai
raisonnable je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est là notre collègue jean
pierre sueur pour le groupe socialiste
sur le le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues il y a
l'horreur du terrorisme et la menace
qu'ils existent qui existent la menace
qu'ils existent la menace terroriste et
qui s'accroît et c'est une réalité face
à laquelle nous avons tous un devoir de
voir pour défendre notre pays nos
compatriotes et pour lutter contre ces
menaces et contre les malheurs qui
peuvent arriver à tout moment
à cet égard le rôle des services de
renseignement est essentielle or vous le
savez tous mes chers collègues jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas de textes
de lois en france
encadrant l'action des services de
renseignement il était nécessaire que ce
texte existe c'est une sécurité
juridique
d'autre part lorsque l'on regarde
attentivement le texte issu du sénat
et je le dis devant nos rapporteur
philippe bachand pierre raffarin devant
madame la présidente de la commission
des lois
nul ne peut soutenir que ce texte ne
comprend pas des avancées importantes y
compris par rapport au texte de
l'assemblée nationale sur deux points
premièrement la protection des libertés
deuxièmement l'accroissement des moyens
de contrôle de la commission nationale
de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement qui est créé par ce texte
par conséquent il faut regarder les
choses en face notre sénat a bien
travaillé et a été fidèle à ce qui est
finalement sa vocation la défense des
libertés
l'accroissement des contrôles mes chers
collègues
plusieurs points ont retenu notre
attention par rapport aux algorithmes
il ya des mots qui font peur comme
algorithmes boîtes noires etc
le texte est extrêmement précis et je
voudrais raisonnée a contrario que ceux
qui refusent toute algorithmes disent
les conséquences qu'ils en tirent ça
veut dire par exemple si on refuse de
regarder un certain nombre de connexions
eh bien on ne peut pas les services ne
peuvent pas regarder concrètement qui se
connecte avec des fichiers avec non
seulement des fichiers mais des sites
qui font l'apologie du terrorisme et qui
encouragent un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes jeunes ou moins jeunes à se
lancer dans l'action terroriste
est-ce qu'il est légitime ou non de
lutter contre cela nous nous pensons que
c'est légitime
et ça veut dire qu'il faut donc pouvoir
procéder aux investigations mais à
condition qu'elles soient ciblées
précisé que les intentions soit affirmé
qu'elles soient définies et par
conséquent c'est tout le contraire de la
surveillance de masse qui a existé
ailleurs et qui a consisté à prendre
toutes les données à capter toutes les
données pour procéder à des milliards de
connexions
cela n'a rien à voir et il faut le dire
avec lactée s'agissant du ministère de
la justice
il y a un apport très grand du sénat
nous avons dit écrit et ça a été l'objet
d'un long débat que le ministère de la
justice n'avait pas vocation à figurer
parmi les organismes oeuvrant pour
mettre en oeuvre des techniques de
renseignement et nous avons trouvé une
rédaction monsieur le rapporteur
président de manière à ce que les
services pénitentiaires signal certain
nombre de choses ils doivent le faire et
que ce soit des services de
renseignement qui s'occupe de mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre
technique bien entendu il faut qu'ils se
parlent il faut qu'il y ait un dialogue
un échange d'informations mais dans des
conditions très précises fixée par la
loi pour la vie privée c'est un
amendement du groupe socialiste
nous avons défini ce que cela signifie
en matière de données personnelles de
secret des correspondances
d'inviolabilité du domicile
pour ce qui est maintenant des données
auxquelles la commission nationale aura
accès
nous avons pu écrire dans la loi notre
groupe il ya contribué par un amendement
que ce recours aux données sera complet
direct et permanent par rapport à ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'il y avait une
dispersion des données eh bien il
reviendra aux services de renseignement
au pouvoir exécutif de faire en sorte
que l'accès de la commission soit direct
complet permanent ce n'est ce pas de
faille et donc la commission aura un
pouvoir considérable
à cet égard je me réjouis que monsieur
le ministre de la défense et monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur est confirmée
ici jeudi dernier que la commission de
contrôle pourrait avoir accès aux
données décrypter produite par le pnc
des c'est à dire la plateforme nationale
de cryptanalyse et de décryptage c'est
quelque chose que le sénat a obtenu et
qui montre l'étendue des pouvoirs
d'investigation et de contrôle de la
commission
quelques regrets mais qui pourront
peut-être être réparée en commission
mixte paritaire monsieur le rapporteur
jean-pierre raffarin nous regrettons que
le mot essentiel et disparus s'agissant
des intérêts économiques parce que nous
pensons qu'il faut faire la différence
entre divers types d'intérêt économique
nous regrettons aussi que le mot paix
civile étaient maintenus s'agissant des
manifestations ce qui peut susciter un
certain nombre de craintes ou
d'incompréhension alors que nous
aurions préféré sécurité nationale enfin
par rapport au fichier des personnes
ayant été condamnées pour terrorisme
nous préférons la l'écriture de
l'assemblée nationale qui eux donnent un
pouvoir de décision aux autorités
judiciaires en la matière mes chers
collègues nous devons dire la vérité il
n'y avait pas de texte sur le sujet il y
en a un ce texte il est nécessaire pour
notre sécurité tel qu'il est il protège
nos libertés il faudrait il faudra être
vigilant mais il protège les libertés et
accroît le contrôle
c'est pour cela que le groupe socialiste
votera pour ce texte
merci à vous chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame esther
benbassa pour le groupe écologiste et
pour sept minutes
vous avez la parole bonjour
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur michel collet ce
biais nous oblige à nous prononcer sur
le choix de société que nous voulons
faire
on se croirait dans une cour de
récréation
bon allez-y c'est un terreau après et ce
ne sont pas les terroristes contre
lesquels il a été élaboré qui doivent
nous dicter ce choix de société à moi
d'accepter de perdre le combat d'avants
ce ces terroristes au moins ceux qui ont
agi sur notre sol notre société a
contribué à les fabriquer hélas mais
pourquoi et comment il faut se poser les
questions
je ne me hasarderai pas ici à suggérer
des réponses forcément très complexe je
crains de toute façon que l'autre
exécutive ne veuille pas les entendre
parce qu'il juge que la répression est
la seule vraie réponse à tout cela je ne
vais pas répéter que rien ne le justifie
l'horreur des actes terroristes dont
nous sommes les témoins mais je sais
aussi que ne pas le faire et s'exposer à
l'accusation indigne de complaisance
vouloir comprendre le phénomène n'est
pas le justifier
mais produire des lois répressives sans
vouloir comprendre est une faute éthique
un manquement grave à l'art de gouverner
moi-même et mon groupe ne sont pas les
seuls à dire nos appréhensions face à ce
texte améliorée dans le sens d'une
protection de l'eau liberté grâce au
travail de la commission des lois et de
ses rapporteurs
il reste encore largement intrusive elle
ne laisse pas d'être inquiets tant pour
les défenseurs des droits humains la
cnil la cncdh
le syndicat de la magistrature l'union
syndicale des magistrats
les associations de défense des libertés
individuelles
public sans compter les hébergeurs les
acteurs de la filière numérique
la liste est longue de ceux qui nous
mettent en garde dès 2014 la commission
des libertés civiles et des affaires
intérieures du parlement européen avait
souligné dans une enquête que je cite
les programmes de surveillance
constituent une nouvelle étape vers la
mise en place de l'état
ultra préventive s'éloignant du modèle
du droit pénal en vigueur dans les
sociétés démocratiques
super g elle est un nouveau pas en ce
sens
l'extension des techniques couplé à
l'extension des motifs de surveillance
pour les tabous t-il à des dérives
incontrôlables
ce pays elle permettra au service de
l'enseignement d'accéder à plus de
donner encore quand on sait qu'ils n'ont
pas pu analyser les données
bien moins volumineuses en leur
possession jusque là ni arrêter les
terroristes avant qu'ils ne commettent
leurs crimes
soyons sérieux aurons-nous jamais un
nombre suffisant la main d'oeuvre
hautement qualifiée d'ingénieurs de
linguistes et c'est indispensable pour
ce travail
ironie de l'histoire
nous allons voter notre petite patrie au
tac à nous quand barack obama signe
outre atlantique ce fruit d'un mac
nous ne voulons donc rien apprendre des
erreurs de ceux qui nous ont précédés
freedom aux états unis liberté ici ces
mots ont le même sens monsieur le
ministre les deux premiers articles de
ce pays elle dessine les contours d'une
nouvelle utopie au loup aliens je vous
le demande mes chers collègues qui
d'entre nous a déjà vu des catcheurs des
boîtes noires qui sait ce qu'elle a à
gogo rythme quand un certain nombre
d'entre nous utilisent encore des
téléphones de notre âge nous allons
ignorant dur
finement des technologies modernes voter
un texte susceptible de devenir une arme
redoutable entre les mains d'hommes de
femmes ou de régimes moins scrupuleux
j'admire votre légèreté et songe avec
effroi aux lois votées dans des passé
trouble par des parlementaires
peut-être hélas aussi léger que nous je
ne doute pas la face de la sincérité de
notre ministre de l'intérieur mais nous
nous croyons mon groupe et moi même
qu'il faut prévoir le pire pour tenter
de l'éviter à temps imaginons un instant
un exécutif de droite d'extrême droite
tentant de faire passer un texte pareil
quand même bon bon bon ça va
la moitié de la france la moitié de la
france pose quand même ça va la moitié
de la france
alertés par une gauche réveiller
seraient descendus dans la rue le groupe
écologiste n'est pas à vous arrêter un
peu comme un bon le groupe écologiste
n'est pas meilleur que l'autre
mais les écologistes une tradition on
vous les avez réveillé en série k o moi
je sais là ça s'est pas mal bon mais les
écologistes ont une tradition cei d'une
défense intransigeante des libertés
c'est aussi ce qui guident mon action
celle colette si vous aviez vécu dans
des pays moins démocratique que le nôtre
vous seriez certainement plus prudent je
rends grâce à notre commission une fois
de plus d'avoir posé quelques verrous
pour stopper des dérives immédiate
je suis heureuse que le prenons
l'amendement de notre garde des sceaux
nous ayons évité de jeter les bases de
la prison de l'avenir celle du
panoptique de bentham celle que décrit
michel foucault à la page 2 134 200
surveiller et punir
je cite induire chez le détenu un état
conscient et permanent de visibilité qui
assurent le fonctionnement automatique
du pouvoir je vous invite également à
relire surveiller et punir très
intéressant
quitte à rester minoritaire ce qui peut
être l'honneur
mon groupe et moi même avons rejoint des
sénateurs comme adam kuperman monsieur
malhuret monsieur mais ahmad moral des
saillies et quelques autres avec qui
j'ai passé deux nuits ici d'un
la compagnie a quelques-uns quelques
autres poursuivent et je me porte garant
des morses allait quelques autres dans
une île et d'allant de mon honneur
quelques autres dans une défense assumé
de liberté de nos concitoyens résistant
aux effets secondaires de l'émotion
suscitée par l'horreur terroristes
l'émotion passe les lois restent les
minoritaires chers collègues ne peut
faire entendre qu'un mince filet de voix
ils ont le devoir de le faire entendre -
ébloui par la pompe faussement
rassurantes des victoires majoritaire
peut-être voit-il plus loin tout
simplement
le groupe écologiste comme quelques
autres ici votera contre ce tête parce
qu'il faut avant tout raison gardée est
resté fidèle à l'essentiel humanisme et
libertés merci merci ma chère collègue
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous allons procéder dans les conditions
prévues par l'article 56 du règlement au
scrutin public
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre les
explications de vote sur la réforme du
renseignement un texte il vient d'être
voté au sénat par 250 et une voix pour
et 68 voix contre
je vous propose maintenant de suivre un
débat sur les collectivités
territoriales et le financement des
lieux de culte
un débat qui fait suite au rapport du
sénateur centriste hervé maurey il en
ressort que soit 100 % des élus sont
favorables au financement public des
lieux de culte existants voilà tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle